>> Neil: ALL RIGHT.
THE SCENE IN MACAU, CHINA.
THE GAMBLING HAVEN OF THE WORLD
AND IT'S BEEN SHUT DOWN FOR
ANOTHER WEEK RIGHT NOW.
COVID CASES BEGIN TO FLARE UP
THERE.
25 MILLION SHANGHAI RESIDENTS
ARE SEPARATELY BEING ASKED TO BE
RETESTED TO SEE IF THINGS ARE
SPREADING THERE AS WELL.
AND WE'RE SEEING LIMITED
MOVEMENT IN HONG KONG ON THE
SAME STORY.
SO ITS REPEATING ITSELF IN ASIA,
JARRING THOSE THAT THOUGHT THAT
WE WERE OVER THERE.
AT LEAST THERE THAT'S NOT THE
CASE.
THERE'S SPIKES IN CASES HERE AS
WELL.
DR. FAUCI KNOWS OF WHAT I SPEAK.
HE HAD TO ENDURE COVID HIMSELF
AND A BAD CASE OF IT.
THE WHITE HOUSE CHIEF MEDICAL
ADVISER JOINING US NOW.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING, DOCTOR?
>> I'M DOING WELL.
THANKS FOR ASKING.
I'M FULLY RECOVERED AND BACK TO
NORMAL THANK GOODNESS.
>> Neil: YOU WERE BEING TREATED
AGAIN.
WAS THERE A FLAIR-UP AFTER THE
FLAIR-UP?
WHAT WAS GOING ON THERE?
>> WHAT HAPPENED WAS, I WAS
INITIALLY INFECTED.
GIVEN MY AGE, BEING A RISK
PERSON AT MY AGE, I TOOK
PAXLAVID.
I FINISHED THE COURSE.
I TESTED MYSELF MONDAY, TUESDAY,
WEDNESDAY AND IT WAS NEGATIVE.
THURSDAY, IT REVERSED BACK TO
POSITIVE.
WITHIN 24 HOURS, I STARTED TO
GET A RETURN OF SYMPTOMS WITH
FEVER, ACHES, WITH SOME LITTLE
BIT OF A COUGH, NOT VERY BAD.
SO I WENT BACK ON PAXLAVID FOR
ANOTHER FIVE DAYS.
THAT CLEARED THINGS UP VERY
WELL.
NOW I'VE BEEN NEGATIVE FOR
MULTIPLE, MULTIPLE DAYS SINCE
THEN.
SO I'M DOING VERY WELL.
THANKS.
>> Neil: LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
THIS.
WHEN PEOPLE HEARD OH, MY GOSH,
THIS HAPPENED TO DR. FAUCI.
EVERYONE KNOWS SOMEONE WHO HAS
GOTTEN THIS AGAIN AND SOMETIMES
AGAIN AFTER THIS.
AND THEY'RE BEGINNING TO WONDER
ABOUT THE REGIMENT FOR TREATING
IT, WHETHER YOU GET A BOOSTER,
TWO SHOTS.
THEY JUST DON'T KNOW.
WHAT DO YOU TELL THEM?
>> WELL, THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLARIFY IT, NEIL.
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT THE
VACCINES THEMSELVES,
PARTICULARLY VACCINE PLUS A
BOOSTER AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME,
FOR MORE THAN ONE BOOSTER, IF
YOU'RE 50 YEARS OLD, YOU CAN GET
TWO BOOSTERS.
ONE OF THE THINGS CLEAR FROM THE
DATA, EVEN THOUGH THE VACCINES
FROM THE HIGH DEGREE OF TRANS
MISS ABILITY DON'T PROTECT
OVERLY WELL AGAINST INFECTION,
THEY PROTECT QUITE WELL AGAINST
SEVERE DISEASE LEADING TO
HOSPITALIZATION AND DEATH.
THAT'S THE REASON WHY AT MY AGE
BEING VACCINATED AND BOOSTED,
EVEN THOUGH IT DIDN'T PROTECT ME
AGAINST INFECTION, I FEEL
CONFIDENT IT MADE A MAJOR ROLE
IN ME PROGRESSING TO SEVERE
DISEASE AND WHY I HAD A
RELATIVELY MILD COURSE.
MY MESSAGE TO PEOPLE THAT SEEM
CONFUSED, THE ANSWER IS IF YOU
WEREN'T VACCINATED, THE
LIKELIHOOD YOU WOULD HAVE MORE
SEVERE COURSE THAN YOU DID HAVE
WHEN YOU WERE VACCINATED.
>> Neil: THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
LOOKING AT IT WITH THE NEW
STRAIN, AND I CAN'T KEEP UP WITH
IT, THIS BA 2.75 OR WHAT HAVE
YOU, IT ALWAYS SEEMED TO BE
MUTATED AND ALWAYS SPREADING.
YET THE COLLECTIVE VIEW OF THE
WORLD IS, WE'RE OVER THIS, TIME
TO MOVE ON, TIME TO LIVE OUR
LIVES AND TIME TO FLY AGAIN.
WE'RE NO LONGER FORCING THOSE
COMING IN FROM OTHER COUNTRIES
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN VACCINATED
OR TESTING NEGATIVE FOR THE
VIRUS ITSELF.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THIS?
>> WELL, WE'RE CERTAINLY NOT
OVER IT.
I THINK THAT PEOPLE HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDABLE DESIRE TO PUT
THIS IN THE REAR VIEW MIRROR AND
SAY WE'RE THROUGH WITH IT.
THAT'S NOT THE REALITY.
WHEN I SAY THAT, I DON'T MEAN TO
SCARE PEOPLE OR GET PEOPLE TO
ALTER THEIR LIVES OR DO ANYTHING
WITH MANDATING.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THAT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MAKING USE
OF THE AVAIL ABLE INTERVENTIONS
THAT WE.
HAVE LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
67% OF THE PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE VACCINATED.
WE RANK VERY LOW WITH DEVELOPED
NATIONS IN THE PROPORTION THAT
ARE VACCINATED.
OF THOSE THAT ARE VACCINATED,
ONLY ABOUT HALF OF THEM HAVE
GOTTEN THEIR FIRST BOOST.
AGAIN, WE'VE GOT TO DO BETTER
THAN THAT.
WE'RE GIVING THE VIRUS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
SPREAD IN OUR COMMUNITY.
IF WE DO SIMPLE THINGS, WHICH
ARE NOT DISRUPTIVE IN ANY MAJOR
WAY, VACCINATION, BOOSTING,
TESTING.
FOR EXAMPLE, IF YOU'RE GOING TO
GO TO A FUNCTION, YOU WANT TO
GET TESTED TO MAKE SURE YOU'RE
NEGATIVE SO IF YOU ARE INFECTED
AND YOU HAVE MINIMAL SYMPTOMS,
YOU DON'T SPREAD IT.
IF YOU HAVE A VULNERABLE PERSON
IN YOUR HOUSE HOLD, SOMEONE THAT
IS ON CHEMOTHERAPY OR IMMUNE
COMPROMISED, YOU MIGHT WANT TO
TEST REGULARLY TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU DON'T INADVERTENTLY BRING
THE VIRUS HOSPITAL TO A
SUSCEPTIBLE PERSON.
THESE ARE EASY THINGS TO DO AND
WE'RE NOT DOING ENOUGH OF IT.
THAT'S THE MESSAGE I WANT OUT.
WE DON'T WANT TO DISRUPT YOUR
LIFE OR FORCE YOU TO DO ANYTHING
BUT DO SOME COMMON SENSE THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO BE
EFFECTIVE.
>> Neil: SO VERY QUICKLY,
DOCTOR, IF PEOPLE ARE REALIZING
YES, THE NUMBER OF CASES HAS
SPIKED ACROSS THE GLOBE, NOTHING
LIKE CHINA, BUT THEY'RE NOT
SEVERE CASES.
VERY FEW HOSPITALIZATION CASES.
THEY'RE SPIKING AS WELL.
THAT MAKES AMERICANS SAY, BEEN
THERE, DONE THAT, OVER THAT.
WHAT DO YOU TELL THEM?
>> I TELL THEM IT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE WITH THAT
ATTITUDE, BUT BE CAREFUL.
WE'RE STILL HAVING AN INCREASE
IN HOSPITALIZATIONS.
WE'RE HAVING MANY MORE
INFECTIONS THAN BEING RECORDED.
WE SAY IT'S ABOUT 140,000 A DAY.
THOSE ARE GROSSLY
UNDERCOULDN'TED.
MANY PEOPLE THAT GET INFECTED DO
A HOME TEST AND DON'T REPORT IT.
WE'RE STILL AROUND 300 DEATHS
PER DAY.
THAT IS AN UNACCEPTABLY HIGH
LEVEL, NEIL.
ALTHOUGH PEOPLE SAY BEEN THERE,
DONE THAT, WE'RE AT A LEVEL THAT
IS NOT AN ACCEPTABLE LEVEL FOR
US.
WE HAVE TO DO BETTER THAN THAT.
>> Neil: I KNOW THIS WAS TOUGH
ON YOU BECAUSE YOU MISSED YOUR
DAUGHTER'S WEDDING TO BE THERE
IN PERSON.
I HOPE EVERYTHING WENT OKAY AND
YOU'RE OKAY.
>> YEAH, I'M FINE.
THANK